hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online jungle now my
previous videos i've talked in detail
about how to disappear once and for all
without leaving a trace one of the basic
rules here is that the new life should
be totally unremarkable if you want to
totally disappear then you want to get
used to attracting as little attention
to yourself as possible hide behind a
mask of an inconspicuous resident of a
big city and disappear into the crowd of
ordinary people right but what if you
don't want to deny yourself anything in
the new life what should you do if
you've accumulated a considerable amount
of capital and now you want your new
life to be one of luxury and
unrestricted freedom is it really
possible in the 21st century to become
the new count of monte cristo a rich man
who appeared from nowhere without
revealing the secret of his origins
that's 72
519 stones in my walls i've counted them
many times but have you named them yet
well today i'm going to tell you all
about how fugitive oligarchs cover their
tracks now do you know this person
[Music]
no
well he went down in the history of
criminology under the name db cooper but
his real name was never actually
uncovered in 1974 on the eve of
thanksgiving he hijacked a plane of the
american company northwest orient
airlines a very polite terrorist handed
the crew a note threatening to detonate
a bomb and demanding 200 dollars in
twenties
along with the money cooper demanded
delivery of four ordinary parachutes fbi
agents complied with the criminals
demands and exchanged the money and
parachutes for hostages at seattle
airport after that the plane took off
towards mexico with the terrorists still
on board and the mysterious db cooper
was never seen again he jumped out of
the plane with the money somewhere in
the vicinity of portland it was only a
few years later that they were able to
find a couple of bundles of the stolen
money but more than 190 000 disappeared
without a trace now according to the
bureau of labor statistics this is
approximately 1.3 million modern dollars
today you might be surprised to know
that around 56 million people in the
world are fortunate enough to be
millionaires so what if one of them
decides to start their life afresh
so this brings me to the first
supposition of our thought experiment my
new character d.b taylor is not hiding
from the police or the mafia he earned
his two or ten million dollars in a
relatively honest way he could have been
engaged in something like the production
of alcohol somewhere in malaysia or
built call centers somewhere in india
it's just important to note that taylor
lives under the radar he's not a
politician or a showbiz star hence he
never attracted the attention of
journalists his photos weren't splashed
across the front pages of tabloids or
featured on the news right and finally
he has no heirs or disgruntled business
partners this person simply decided to
disappear and used one of the methods i
described in the last video to do so the
problem is that is extremely difficult
for a person without a past or history
to become part of today's open world or
maybe it's not so difficult well that's
what we're going to be looking into so
without further ado it's time to welcome
count monty taylor
[Music]
by the way in preparation for this video
i was wondering whether it's actually
possible to buy an aristocratic title
these days and as it turns out yes it is
and it's even quite inexpensive in fact
you yourself can become a lord or lady
for a mere 36 euros this is exactly how
much it costs to buy a plot in the
picturesque glencore valley in the north
of scotland now with that money you can
of course only buy one square foot of
land but that's enough to officially
become a scottish lord of course this is
an honorary title only you won't be
allowed to attend a meeting in the house
of lords but it will look quite
impressive on a business card especially
on the other side of the atlantic and do
you think this is a joke for americans
don't think so perhaps you recognize
this person now this is scott disick
he's an entrepreneur and a participant
in a scandalous reality show a couple of
years ago he actually went down the
route of purchasing himself such a title
and now calls himself lord disick
but what if you want something a little
grander not a problem you just have to
spend a little bit more money for
example it will cost 15 000 pounds to
become a baron from buckinghamshire and
you can become the 27th lord or lady of
cotes bedun for just 3 250 pounds
and you know these are real titles
to be honest i even thought about such a
purchase for myself for a couple of
seconds
you are truly the cruelest tyrant in the
kingdom your lordship such a title can
be very helpful for said db taylor to
start a new life after all he needs to
be earning something right
well or at least he needs to create the
illusion of earnings for banks and tax
authorities in most cases you wouldn't
be able to just transfer money from say
in english to an american bank aml
employees will have too many questions
about the origin of said funds however
sometimes it is actually possible to
legalize such money through the
fictitious sale of equities securing
non-existent loans and so on now of
course we've already spoken about these
methods more than once but these methods
have huge drawbacks and if we're
discussing them openly on youtube then
you can be sure that the experts are
more than aware of them too so i'm going
to come up with something new
the first thing that came to mind was to
become a star of the wine business now
firstly our db taylor is an english
aristocrat and who knows more about wine
than english lords and secondly it's a
solid and respectable occupation which
is easy to finance by the way from the
funds of some offshore company for
example a small but wealthy company from
the virgin islands can order lord db
taylor to examine their wine collection
which is stored in the luxembourg
freeport the details of the contract of
course are extremely confidential but
the amount is large and absolutely legal
so that aml experts don't even hold the
slightest of doubts for a couple of
thousand dollars we will create taylor's
very own website and fill it with short
reviews about expensive wines of course
we won't even have to try them all texts
will be written by hired copywriters
based on reviews from the vivino app and
also articles by real experts we'll also
spend some more money on promoting the
site through contextual advertising and
once we've done this well the image of
the new critic is ready the only weak
point in this regard is the tailor will
actually have to genuinely master the
basic concepts from the world of wine in
order not to accidentally slip up in the
clarity of chablis however this isn't
much of a problem because the necessary
knowledge can be obtained in a matter of
days via online courses the w set 2
level will cost about 300 pounds and is
more than enough to hold a decent
conversation with most wine lovers and
enthusiasts in addition the trade of
elite bottles opens doors for d.b taylor
to lead an active social life do you
remember the brilliant story of the
fraudster rudy kenyawan parties stars
champagne splashes
but wait i think i've got a better idea
here
splashes of champagne sometimes smell of
gasoline sweat excitement and huge
budgets right i'm talking about
automobile racing
of course like any british man i've
dreamed of gently stroking formula one
cars since childhood you know the
cheapest tickets actually for a rated
silverstone now cost about 2 000 euros
it's more expensive than some of those
aristocratic titles i was speaking about
indeed expensive tickets to the paddock
club can actually no longer be bored and
the incredible lewis hamilton has taken
the interest in formula one to a new
height
so what if the name db taylor appears on
the side pods of one of the teams well
it's more realistic than you think the
first advertisements on cars appeared in
1968 the lotus team painted the car in
the colours of the gold leaf cigarette
company for many years tobacco and
alcohol companies have spent almost more
on the sponsorship of car races than the
car manufacturers did themselves the red
and white colours of marlborough blue
mild 7 yellow camel i mean the coloring
of the cars from the golden age of
formula 1 was dictated by these tobacco
giants but the beginning of the 2000s
the european union banned such
advertising and in place of the departed
corporations came rather strange slogans
do you remember the t minor scandal of
nigerian prince malik ibrahim have you
ever used the i time app or the sugar
book website
well these kinds of sponsorships more
often than not are just an access all
areas pass to the world of the rich and
famous the first time this was actually
used was by an extravagant financier
from belgium john pierre van
he claimed to have developed a
mathematical module that reliably
predicts the stock price van rossum
founded moneytron his own fund for
trading on the stock exchange right and
the sponsorship contract with a young
team onyx also helped him to look for
wealthy clients the team lasted only a
year and a half in formula one but van
rossum himself managed to raise capital
of around 860 million dollars and since
van rossum's time and a lot of petrol
later sponsorship has become much more
expensive the teams keep the exact
numbers of sponsorship contracts uh well
kept secret but a few years ago the
daily mail journalists gave some
interesting figures it turned out that
even the most budget advertising on
lewis hamilton's racing suit costs
around a million dollars but really
that's not much for getting yourself a
place on the uniform of a seven time
world champion is it i think that if i
target teams that don't have quite as
many championship titles to the name
i'll be able to take a prominent place
on the suits of races and cars for the
same money but advertising dubious
investment funds or non-existent tenants
drinks is no longer accepted in formula
one and therefore i'm actually gonna
have to come up with a company whose ceo
will be db taylor
i think it will be social highly
technical
innovation foundation by taylor or shift
for short
now here i'm going to use the famous
silicon valley principle fake it till
you make it this is what happens when
you work to change things look the
protagonist of our hypothetical scenario
isn't going to conduct fraudulent
activities or attract third-party
investments like van rossum did the
foundation's task is to provide a
financial alibi the sponsors of the
organization will be offshore companies
that actually hold taylor's money part
of the money will go to advertising and
car racing in other parts to simulate
legitimate activities perhaps some
sociological research or demographic
investigations and hired copywriters
will write articles about these studies
in addition you could actually take
advantage of hot topics floating around
in the media for example the launch of a
collection of digital clothing that will
draw attention to the food crisis in
africa or release a selection of nft
tokens with photos of endangered animals
right
social problems and high technology are
a recipe for perfect news taylor himself
will of course be the main beneficiary
of the company but most importantly he
will have something to talk about over a
glass of champagne at the paddock club
the only weakness here in the scheme is
if one of the rich and famous people
that taylor befriends genuinely wants to
sponsor shift with real money however
let's hope the lawyers will be able to
delay those deals
[Music]
now if you're rich it becomes difficult
to get lost in the world do you remember
that in a past video i actually told you
how to correctly get rid of a mobile
phone well being a millionaire makes
things a little more complicated for
example any network user can find out
where your yacht or business jet is
located right now
these things constantly transmit signals
with their coordinates and this
information makes its way into public
databases and sites and therefore you
need to go to marine traffic and you'll
be able to watch the movement of
millionaires in real time
and you know getting rid of your
favorite yacht is a bit more difficult
than throwing away say an old iphone now
i began to study this topic for a very
good reason do you remember the name of
the criminal with whom i started today's
video
well db cooper made history not only by
jumping out of a plane with a duffel bag
full of dollars
but after this incident the ladders of
passenger aircraft began to be equipped
with a special mechanism and it was
named the cooper blade now during the
flight the airflow presses against the
blade and this actually presses it
against the hatch and becomes impossible
to open it during flight now simple
invention prevented new attempts at
hijacking planes in any case i hope my
little thought experiment today will
allow ml specialists to look into our
world through the eyes of a potential
fraudster
my name is bradley and it's been my
pleasure to pilot you on this peacefully
pleasant parade perry said prolifically
passionate digital protections of the
online jungle and i will see you in the
next video thanks for joining us
[Music]